sur twitter on a longtemps connu mamadou
seck pas qu'ils s'amusaient à faire des
blagues sur cette section faire passer
ces élèves là pour des nuls des abrutis
on connaît aussi une série sur youtube
qui s'appelle les sait pas qui fait des
millions de vues et qui met en scène des
élèves très très bête face à un
professeur très très autoritaire qui
n'hésitent pas à les prendre par le col
et ses représentations sont évidemment
très éloignée de la réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
classes de segpa c'est une classe une
section qu'on appelle section
d'enseignement général et professionnel
adapté
c'est une section où on va mettre des
élèves qui expérimentent grande
difficulté à partir du cm2 et qui ont
donc besoin d'un enseignement adapté en
réalité les élèves de segpa se
retrouvent ici pour tout un tas de
raisons ça peut être des problèmes
sociaux des problèmes familiaux des
problèmes liés à la santé parfois parce
qu' un enfant qu'il ya des hauts des
rendez vous à l'hôpital assez fréquent
trois quatre fois par semaine
forcément ça a des conséquences sur sa
scolarité on attribue à l'école de façon
erronée le devoir de trier les élèves de
dire qui est le plus intelligent qui est
le plus digne de mérite c'est un rôle
qui n'appartient pas du tout à l'école
l'école est là pour faire progresser les
élèves quel que soit leur niveau initial
[Musique]
la première fois que j'ai dit à des
copains que j'allais me retrouver en
segpa
il m'avait conseillé pourrir un de
mettre un gilet pare balles avant d'y
aller parce que soi-disant ce serait des
gamins extrêmement dangereux et violents
moi même en y allant j'avais mes propres
représentations je pensais que j'allais
me retrouver face à des grands garçons
qui allaient rentrer s'affaler sur sur
la table et me regarder sans bouger le
petit doigt et il y en a eu il y avait
ces garçons là pas mal mais il ya aussi
vu des garçons timides les garçons
mélancolique des filles aussi qu'ils
sont aussi exposés à l'échec scolaire
plus que la dangerosité plus que la
colère je trouve que ce qui relie tous
ces élèves entre eux c'est plutôt une
grande fragilité une forme d'impuissance
il arrive en 6e segpa après avoir connu
beaucoup d'échecs
c'est ça en fait qu'il est relié
pratiquement tous le sentiment
d'incapacité d'impuissance de fragilité
et même de honte parce que des années
après on me demande encore de fermer la
porte lorsqu'il y à des camarades qui
passe pour ne pas qu'ils voient que il
se trouve dans la classe des mules
j'avais pris un covoiturage avec avec un
entrepreneur qui était progressiste sur
plein d'aspects on a eu une discussion
super intéressante
et puis arrive la question du fatidique
du tu fais quoi dans la vie et je
m'explique un peu ce que je fais et là
il explique en fait dans l'école
d'autrefois ça pouvait pas exister ça
parce que les échecs scolaires c'était
quelque chose de nouveau finalement que
c'était dû au smartphone que c'était dû
à la télé que les jeunes n'étaient plus
face à des professeurs comme autrefois
donc qu'il ya une crise de l'autorité
est en fait je suis toujours très étonné
que on essaye de trouver les solutions
contre l'échec scolaire en regardant
vers le passé parce que autrefois bien
sûr qu'il y avait de l'échec scolaire
mais ces élèves qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui de se lève à besoins
éducatifs particuliers ses élèves que
j'ai en face de moi
on les appelait autrefois si on regarde
les archives institutionnels des idiots
d1 gouvernable des imbéciles dans les
placer sur ce qu'on appelle les chaînes
métriques d'intelligence d' alfred binet
et petite anecdote le test parfois
consistait à entourer la femme la plus
belle parmi une série de dessins donc je
sais pas comment on pouvait dire qu'un
garçon était intelligent ou pas à
travers cet exercice qu'on dit que
l'école c'était mieux avant moi j'aime
pas rentrer dans ce débat parce que
c'est un long et interminable débat mais
ce que je peux dire avec certitude c'est
que pour mes élèves à moi pour les
élèves à besoins éducatifs particuliers
non l'école n'était pas mieux avant